so fast he's a CDM I'm we like said
we're kind of a next generation or
that's kind of a cheesy marketing term
you probably actually use this without
knowing about this this is some of our
customers we've got Twitter on there BBC
the British government runs through us
which is kind of cool though bit scary
this is also some of our customers
I realize actually in retrospect some of
those who duplicated I promise you
that's me screwing up not me trying to
pad the stuff but yes this is gonna be
the last video oriented than some of the
other stuff although we will shove some
video stuff in at the end this is more
about just like why we're different why
we did a CDN and sort of just go on from
there so yeah if I rush through stuff I
apologize grab me afterwards I'm gonna
be at the cocktail party trying to serve
my sort of whatever the sine waves or
whatever worthy they're the things
circadian rhythms that's one sine waves
yeah so people when we started off
people asked us like why why did you
build a CDN you've got it you've got
Akamai they're the 800-pound gorilla in
the room you've got edge cacica
limelight and Amazon's in the business
like why would you do this and basically
is because we were really unhappy with
the way that the CDN market was at the
time you didn't get a lot of control
like configuration was really crappy
like when you made a configuration
change it could take our best minutes
sometimes hours to do stuff you don't
have a lot of control over your data
like you know when you wanted to
purchase up a game like minutes or hours
to change stuff which you know when
you're dealing with a modern content
site and you know you didn't get a lot
of visibility and you were locked into
these year-long contracts it was crappy
it was just a really crappy way of doing
stuff and it didn't really fit in with
the way that we do development now like
yeah sure when we used to though we
released once a week or once a month
that was fine but now people do 10 12 20
releases a day that didn't really work
that well and also the sport was kind of
crap like every time you found out the
support thing you dreaded you had to go
through your your sales rep and then
they would they try and upsell you on
something and be like no I just want to
figure out how to do this thing like I
don't want to have to pay for two hours
of professional services so we were like
enough we will build our own and and it
worked out good and this is sorry this
is our pop map it's actually
already out of date Stockholm is already
up a soccer is coming up I think
sometime soon we're looking at Brazil
we're also looking at a bunch of other
places Taipei so South Africa it's
actually really easy for us to bring out
pops so like based on market stuff it
can be really you know if you if you've
got you're looking on here and going
well you don't have a place where I need
it come talk to us anyway because it's
really easy for us to bring up a pop
unless there's really odd local and this
is really odd local laws like Brazil is
actually real pain in the ass for
various reasons come talk to me
afterwards when I'm drinking because it
makes me want to drink ah so why would
you use why would you use fascinated
like this is the kind of sales event
when I started off like so when we were
starting off doing I suggested one of
our so it was a slogan should be faster
cheaper faster cheaper better pic 3
turns out that's why I should never be
in marketing but basically we can make
you we basically can make your site
faster we can lower your costs and we
can make your site more reliable and you
know which we're basically trying to
lower your total cost of ownership and
it's all you know it's total cost of
ownership is made up of multiple assets
and it's everything from like
reliability to geographic distribution
its control to visibility to how fast
you can go and do stuff and so really we
want it to be kind of part of that view
we can reduce your cap X and up X by
going through us you don't have to have
as many origin servers and so therefore
your capex is lower not and also our
bandwidth costs are going to be lower
than yours because we've got economies
of scale unless your Google in which
case but even Google users so you know
they should tell you something
and so we can reduce your are pegs as
well if you're using us we've got a
really sweetheart deal with Google when
it comes to egress from Google Cloud
storage so that will low your Google
cost like thank you very much Google and
go and talk to ourselves guys they'll
tell you I kind of kind of how much
you'll be saving you don't need as much
redundancy you can have one data center
and we will take care of it all you need
you don't need quite as many data
centers we will reduce your bounce rate
like the faster your site is and the
more reliable is the more likely people
are to come back
and because of that because of the
faster faker will increase your PageRank
and so that means more people will come
to you will increase your revenue
because there is a really really
well-known link between how fast your
site loads and how much money people
spend on it you know and you can
intuitively kind of grasp that if you go
to a site and you are like trying to buy
something for it and it takes two
seconds for each page to load you don't
look up for items and then go you know
what I'm giving up whereas if it slows
really quickly you're much more likely
spend time around and because of that
people can have spend more time on site
so you know there's that neat symmetry
we'll do some stuff you will increase
other things and the reason why we kind
of can do this is that back in the early
90s like sorry well early 90s that was
yeah sort of back in the back in the
late 90s early 2000s like really content
was basically inside the static content
like images CSS JavaScript all that kind
of stuff or it's fully dynamic stuff
like CG you know running cookie pull
scripts through my Perl or like ASP or
PHP 3.0 for anybody who's like old
school and it was mostly you know those
two concepts completely separate it was
like the stuff as I static or is dynamic
and you never the twain shall meet
nowadays we have this term we started
using this term event-driven content
mostly because we needed some sort of
marketing term rather than try to
explain it every time but that's
basically stuff like not content doesn't
actually change that often so you're
looking at stuff like front page of a
newspaper or something like that like
everybody's looking at the same front
page it's dynamically generated but
realistically it's sticking around for
five minutes or something like that you
know it doesn't actually change that
much something triggers it that causes
have changed somebody publishes a new
story stock market changes a new event
happens or something like that you get a
new mail all that stuff is event-driven
it's not truly dynamic so that's what we
can come in and that's actually a huge
amount of your stuff and we can cash
that for you then you can save yourself
a huge amount of you can make your page
a lot faster you can save yourself a
huge amount of bandwidth so statically
class stuff we can drastically increase
your cash it ratio and you know it sorry
I just realize the conversion of this
from PowerPoint hasn't actually gone as
well as that so stuff is going off so
you know with kind of traditional static
stuff we can cache it really far really
we use map sort of matter we we call
these commodity servers because they're
built off commodity parts but you know
they tend to have 768 gigs of RAM
they tend to have like terabytes and
terabytes of SSDs we wrote our own file
system it seemed like a really good idea
at the time
the reason we do that is we don't need a
regular file system all we need to do is
put cached objects down on disk and if
we can look after the fire we can look
after the SSD we can get read all of
that overhead
the smaller the the cached object is on
disk the more stuff we can stick and
stick on the SSD and if we look after
the SSD stead of burning out after three
months we got we've got SSDs which are
now three years old and the advantage
you're using SSDs is that they are
really really fast and I'm going to go
into that a little bit kind of later on
we're really good for this kind of stuff
like you may notice at the bottom that's
us we're really fast cash point is like
a monitoring and testing service so also
look how smooth we are so we're calm
ordered people something that's dynamic
content this is a purely dynamic content
I think Akamai calls this DSA dynamics
light acceleration they sell it as a as
an add-on I'm not trying to bag on
Akamai they're you know they're big for
a reason and they do some really really
important work but like just using the
kind of terms that they use dynamic
content you know we can't you can't cash
it let's say it's like the current time
or something like that you can't cash it
when somebody's like very very personal
data you can you can't cash it that's
fine we will accelerator and the reason
why we can do that is like weaken it you
can have an initial connection to our
one of our pups ervice which is closer
to your users the TCP are the three-way
handshake the TTP does that the start
will be a lot quicker because the
latency between your user and our pop is
going to be a lot better and then
between our pops
we've got we keep people eyes between
our pops and we know that the best route
between them and at the other end we
will then go back to your origin servers
and again that the three-way handshake
will be a lot faster between our what we
call our shield node and between your
origin that will be a lot faster and
also like we can keep we can try and
keep a keep alive back to you so even
we can't cash something we will make it
faster and for us though instead of
being an additional product that you you
buy and it's like an extra like line
item on your bill for us it's the worst
case scenario when we can't do anything
else like we will try and cat we're Pro
and hard as possible to cash stuff but
if we can't cash it we will still make
it faster and that's just considered
well you know in the worst case scenario
we'll be there so I won't read the
quotes from the side so so yeah once
again like me Rach I'm not entirely sure
what happened on February the 21st
apparently everybody had a bad day
so yeah we we just like showing these
graphs that nice so then we can't go
this third type of caching and this is
like that what we call a vent Riven
content and that stuff like API mobile
staff news articles user-generated
content like wiki's we actually kind of
start it off as it's part of Wikia so if
you've ever used like I you may or may
not know about we care but basically if
you go to a game site or if you go to
Wikipedia if you're in stores or if you
go to the Muppet wiki if you're into
Muppets and if you're not I don't really
want to know you okay
then use wiki and wiki an intern you're
actually using us and you know you think
about a wiki like media where here is
not the best piece of Britain piece of
software it's great but it's not the
best written piece of software it's
really slow and you know you think about
it's a very very long tail and if you
had to do kind of traditional stuff of
baking all the pages and uploading them
to a CDN then that would be terrible
because you'd be uploading a lot of
stuff you don't know if it's gonna get
used like nobody's really necessarily
going to look at the list of every the
names of every single of Luke
Skywalker's lightsabers if you gave the
names I'm picking an example completely
random here but you know so but they
when when a wiki changes when a new
world you know wow we key you know when
well we could gets updated a lot when a
new one comes out then stuff changes
really quickly you can't be you can't be
waiting eight minutes let alone eight
hours for a page to updated ecommerce
sites are obviously a really big thing
they're kind of just like content
publishing sites but when prices change
and inventors change you really need to
update the page quickly sports scores
another thing like they don't change for
ages like the game that
the Dodgers game last night like doesn't
change for ages but then when it does
change you really need to update quickly
so yeah and people like that we've got
the Guardian I always bring out the
guarding because it's my first sale even
though I'm an engineer it was kind of
weird it was a bittersweet moment for me
I kind of felt a bit of my soul died and
Shazam and all that kind of content
survey that so and Conde Nast and so
wide runs through us which gave me a
massive guitro so the features that
really kind of do that we have real-time
purging when you purge content for us
you can say be gone and we will be like
okay and 150 milliseconds worldwide is
gone and that's huge we actually have
three different ways of purging stuff
you can either purged by URL you can
purge by something we call surrogate key
purging which is when you can tag
content with multiple keys so each pit
of content can have multiple keys
attached to it and each key can have
multiple bits of multiple objects
attached to it so it's a really handy
way of grouping stuff together so you
know if you've got a pet you know the
obvious thing is like if you've got a
new an article on a site you've got the
page it's got one or more pages with one
or more images or assets an hour you
tagged them all with the same article ID
if that article needs to get updated you
purge it all those things are gone you
can also tag it with the author surf you
the New York Times and you find out one
of your authors has been plagiarizing
everything and you need to purge
everything by the author do one call and
it's all gone we do real-time blogs this
would be useless like you caching stuff
would be absolute useless if you didn't
always gone on with it and so we can
stream logs back to you in real time and
we again will we'll go into a bit of
that later I'm kind of skipping over
stuff just in case I get over go over
time we have this Origin shield which is
this idea that we can you can't it you
can you can do multi-tiered caching so
basically like you know stuff comes into
one of our edge servers and then we will
reroute any cache misses
back to an Origin thing an Origin pop
which is writing it as close as possible
to your origin and then that will shield
all your requests it will make sure that
you only have one request that are going
back to your your origin it protects you
from stampeding herd and also like I
said it gives this much much faster kind
of response because we know the best
route between all our pops and we can
keep keep alized between our like shield
pops and with your origin so and we also
do
request collapsing if two people are
coming and asking for the same better
concert at the same time we will
recognize that and then collapse it down
into one request so again just when you
purge something you don't see this
massive spike in traffic which would be
you know which mean you still have to
keep this kind of redundant hardware
around so the benefit so that should be
pretty obvious like your site is a lot
faster you can handle you can handle
unpredictable traffic spikes you know if
you're you know your the Boston Globe
and like you know sort of like you
finally get into the World Series or
something like that then you know you're
you're gonna see a massive spike in
traffic you know he'll The Guardian
newspaper and a royal baby is born then
that's going to happen as well we also
give you this real-time configurability
you know you can you can change your
config and have it deployed everywhere
in like two seconds worldwide and
everything is API driven we do have a UI
on top of that but everything is API
driven because we don't know how you're
going to be how you want to configure us
if you want to build us into your like
puppet chain or your bite chef or
whatever then that's cool if you want to
rigger sense or something that's
absolutely fine we we want to work with
you how you work not force you to work
we're how we do so and we're trying to
give you total control over your content
you can send us back cache headers you
can override everything in our UI you
can actually upload edge scripting it's
why I write everything we we don't know
how you use your content so we want to
give you the control to do stuff it's
also kind of proactive laziness on our
part like the more you can do stuff the
less we have to do and that's really
great especially back when we were
starting off it meant I could actually
sleep and spend more time welding giant
metal ears and so we're trying to lower
your capex and and basically like the
way we were able to do this like when we
started off people were kind of how
you're gonna compete about against
acolyte how you're gonna compete against
edge cats how you're gonna compete
around limelight you know there's so
much bigger they're gonna have economies
of scale you're gonna be too expensive
and basically they were all built on you
may notice the wide the back of my
thinks is life's two to two shorties and
90 CDN all of them build their network
it'll back in the early 2000s when the
internet was very different it was
crappy like you know late 90s early 2000
things we were you crappy now things are
a lot better
and we can do stuff bye-bye building
much fewer pops at internet backbones
rather than at kind of local ISPs we can
build much larger pops we can use SSDs
the vapor on with using regular hard
drives is the more space you've got they
are the slower the average sheet time is
going to be because there because the
sea time is linear
sorry is yeah it is linear compared to
compared to size because you know it
just takes wider you know it's just it's
a spinning bit of rust with a head
moving over it so it's going to take
longer today with an SSD lookup times a
completely constant so we can have much
much larger pops much much larger drives
which means it's much more likely your
stuff is going to be in cash SSE is a
really high cost per gigabyte but
they're really low cost per I of um I
mean we were talking about you're
talking about 70,000 70,000 like I was
for second thread to like seven for like
a really high-end hour drive or
something like that yeah so we can get a
lot more performance out of our pops we
got a lot more efficiency and then we
can pass those costs RL and that's the
low increased fat cashier ratio just
means you get less traffic going back to
you which is really good and if you
think about it like we can increase your
cash hit ratio from ninety to say 95
percent it doesn't sound that impressive
but actually what we've just done is
half your origin traffic back so that
means you can get rid of half your
servers and not only that but then all
that content like serving stuff in the
cache is gonna be so much faster than
having to go back to your origin you
running whatever you know app rails app
whatever PHP in the background and then
go back again like we've just saved that
request has gone from being 500
milliseconds a second or something like
that it's gone back we're responding to
it within 20 milliseconds so your page
is gonna be a lot lot faster and then
I've already kind of talked about origin
shield quite a lot so I went and and we
trying to give you more control like we
should be integrated into your
development cycle like when people think
about cloud when they think about Google
cloud platform and they think about AWS
and stuff like that the reason why it
took off is because people can it fits
in another way that you do stuff it
doesn't feel like this vendor you're
throwing stuff into it feels like it's
much more part of your development stack
and okay that worked we wanted to be
complete self service with a shouldn't
you shouldn't have to find up in connect
holder professional services just to
change something when you push a
configuration change to happen in
seconds all configuration should be
version so you should be able to
rollback and between those two things it
gives you a lot more power to to do
stuff and a lot more freedom to
experiment like if you made a change and
it took like five hours to sort of
propagate and then when you finished it
was screwed up
you'd be like oh god that's really bad
now we're gonna make a change away at
another five hours for it to fix itself
and you're gonna be much less likely to
change things you're gonna be much more
worried it's gonna feel a lot more
fragile you can make a change notice
immediately from the real-time feedback
from the analytics and the logs that
something's gone wrong and immediately
either roll back will make push to fix
you're much more likely to go like okay
well I'm gonna try other stuff now I'm
gonna try and play around and see what
more stuff I can actually move to the to
the edge servers and then that's going
to be more beneficial to you so we were
trying to like we really wanted to
create a system on which you could do
that we said all functionality is
available by the API or a UI and we've
got this IDI really powerful edge
crypting based on something called
varnish configuration language or VCL
VTL is basically a domain-specific
language to let you do anything with
with HTTP it's really really powerful
and so that's pretty so you can do a lot
more stuff you can move a lot more
content to the edge and we've got stuff
on there we've got like edge
authorization and paywall we can do
stuff based on GOI P and G restrictions
so if you've got content that shouldn't
be shown - it shouldn't be shown to some
people but should be shown to other you
can do that through authorization you
can do mobile dice device detection you
can do shopper prioritization it's when
you know if your origin server your
credit card payment server is kind of
pretty loaded during the during the
holiday period you can sit there and go
okay well we'll just we'll show up a
warning page saying hey we're really
sorry your order is very important to us
you'll be be able to pay soon but then
you can also look and go oh this
person's got the VIP flag well this
person's got like $10,000 worth and
stuff in their shopping basket we're
gonna silently move them off to the VIP
server and just like allow them to go
through as well we can do your load
balancing for you our CEO is very very
much against f5s he really hates them so
he basically one of that built in and we
can do stuff like data collections
tougher Internet of Things stuff that's
less relevant to the to the rendering
people here but I thought I'd mention it
anyway so and this is kind of an example
of ECL this is a way of like having like
a different addition for your for your
content so like somebody's coming from
international somebody's coming from
mobile so if you could redirect around
it's kind of a contrived example but
it's in here for just Ritalin suited
purposes
I said content purging happens in 150
milliseconds you can purge my URL you
have complete control over what is
defined as a cache key so you can make
some stuff unique some stuff not so that
can include say somebody's language
which they prefer to speak or where not
the URL has Eurail parameters or
something in it and you can purge by
this surrogate key stuff that I was
talking about so I'm rushing because I'm
looking I'm noting the clock's ticking
down and like I said we want to give you
more visibility so we've got real-time
logging with completely customizable
logs we give you real-time stats with
the historical stats and this gives you
the greater confidence mailto change and
the most of the more confidence you got
the more stuff you're going to cache
more cache and stuff your caching with
us the more you owe is money and that
makes us happy so that was a joke but
it's true but it's also a joke
I probably sketch oh this is like an
example and I don't think I probably got
time to go through it yeah we can we can
cache content the even if you've got
tracking cookies inside your content we
can cache that that we can so you allow
people to you can track people through
your site normally a cat tracking cookie
would be unique to a user and that means
you can't that means you can't really
that means you can't really like cache
that at all what we can do is generate
the code the cookie at the edge and then
track it back and then send it back back
via log so you can even if you've got a
site with a tracking cookie you can
still cache it
you can precisely follow village video
viewing like if you using HLS or HDS or
dash or something like that like each of
those is it's video separated into
chunks so you can for a log event for
each chunk you can also sent the how
many bytes we sent back versus the
content length of the chunk and say the
session ID of the user ID if the user is
logged in so then if you are a large
specialist video site so for example
they're not actually a customers but
they did a thing which showed that
people tend to watch the first 30
seconds of the videos skip about 3
minutes in and then skip to the end but
you could see that through the logging
they're not actually a customer
but they wrote a really interesting
essay on it and this was kind of this is
other stuff that we can show you for
real-time tracking so this is from the
Superbowl we call this the beyoncé fact
or the Beyonce drop in certainly so this
is where you can see where all the
advert breaks are interesting enough
during the Superbowl people stop being
on the internet during the adverts so we
can actually tell you which adverts were
most successful during the break and
that we can also tell you when Beyonce
came on stage and we can also tell you
that Beyonce was far far more popular
than Bruno Mars in and the Red Hot Chili
Peppers it's like way more popular and I
suspect that's why Katy Perry was on
this year so I don't think I've got time
to go into like how we're working with
Google Google cloud platform but
basically it's a but we basically
seamlessly integrate it into them you
use us you get lower lower u.s. across
from Google and you get really really
good you get really good performance
boost so and Google also and they've
been really very first up I basically
mean touring the world going meeting all
the GCP people which is why I'm really
jet-lagged caffeinated and why I'm
speaking so fast so and so it basically
I'm out of time so if you've got any
more questions come grab me afterwards
or touch me at the event